chaque oeil gaspard proust
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau hein s'effacer ça m'agace
tard alors ça fait quoi d'être au
chômage super avoue gaspard pour elle
est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
allez ça va ça va
économiquement florange vivement que ça
ferme enfin qu'ils arrêtent un peu avec
leurs besoins permanents de faire fondre
de l'acier c'est quand même dingue mais
j'ai en 2012 il ya des gens qui ont la
nostalgie des boulots de dix neuvième
siècle inventeurs franchement lakshmi
mittal c'est un humaniste quoi qu'ils
aient envie de travailler aujourd'hui
avec un casque de chantier et 8 heures
par jour devant un four à 1000 degrés
dans une odeur d'acier grillé comme
c'est à croire que les gars de florange
il se masturbe en lisant germinal dans
la psychologie des mecs le week end ils
font quoi des barbecues à sec juste pour
évoquer le boulot tu
moi je préfère être au chômage très
honnêtement que c'est pas sport cette
histoire dans de balleure c'est assez
tragique c'est normal c'était inventé en
allemagne de l'est
tu vois que je suis le truc le plus
joyeux qui vient d'allemagne de l'est
c'est merkel on va de la marge
et un handballeur en fait c'est quoi
c'est le mec qui est pas assez doux et
des pieds pour faire footballeur pas
assez viril pour jouer au rugby mais
assez con quand même pour jouer au
ballon
[Applaudissements]
alors
les l'histoire des paris c'est quand
même le casse du siècle d'habitude sur
un pari pour montpellier c'est 3000
euros en moyenne là ils ont mis 70
milles mais comme ce n'était pas assez
discret dit ouais ma copine qui
travaille à la télé va acheter les
billets quoi pour la fille travaille à
la télé faste et nrj12
c'est pas la télé c'est une radio avec
une webcam
est-ce que tout et tout ça pourquoi tout
pour gagner 250 mille euros alors ok à
19 c'est quoi l'idée s'acheter une
ferrari en copropriété
faire du covoiturage wave asie prête les
clés temps c'est triste quand les
footballeurs ils voient ça ils jettent
une pièce
d'ailleurs je me demande vu que l'équipe
de montpellier est décimée est-ce qu'ils
ont été assez intelligent pour parier
sur les effets de futures
tu as vu le gaz par l'humour intelligent
enfin bref
alors il paraît que guaino a dit que
tout était truqué dans la course aux
parrainages
c'est ce que c'est pas moi c'est vous
avez parlé combien sur des fêtes de copé
n'ont pas pauvre copé il prend tout le
temps moi franchement copé tout le temps
cette polémique là sur le racisme
anti-blanc fin c'est purement à
l'ex-terroriste en france il ya plus de
blancs que de noir il va pas défendre
les peaux-rouges coiffer les
émois moi je sens un vrai racisme
anti-blanc quoi moi avec ma tronche je
ne fais jamais contrôlé flotteurs façon
le contrôle au faciès ça n'existe pas
c'est une rumeur c'est facile et jeunes
des cités se font interpeller quatre
fois par jour c'est juste parce qu'ils
ont des noms plus compliqué à retenir
façon politiquement ça avance taubira
veut fermer des prisons c'est quand même
con et que l'école c'est le seul endroit
qui fixe des limites aux gamins
avaient proposé des peines de
substitution à la prison reste il faut
qu'on m'explique c'est quoi une peine de
substitution à la prison un patch qui
diffuse une odeur de matons
[Applaudissements]
je comprends que les jeunes soit
déboussolé après des drames un regard de
travers bon strabisme grande cause
nationale cet avion
je me disais la joconde avec son sourire
un peu énigmatique tu vois les dés en
bulle dans les faubourgs de grenoble
effet pas 100 m c'est la tournant
alors attention il ya quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de tout rené coty
il est boosté à y revient de l'onu il
sent plus quoi c'est le seul mec tu vas
il a ringardisé ban ki moon a on peut
être moins charismatique le truc dans
[Rires]
non mais tu l'as vu la ce a grenoble
sous la fenêtre faire son imitation de
sarko que ça c'est vraiment mon mauvais
jeu renseigner quoi tu vas l'autre qu'il
alpague façon à livreuse d'encorner à
rungis là ouais on a voté pour vous
il ya déjà droit de vote des étrangers
ah pardon madame
alors lui répond sécurité justice
réussite c'est pas jean michel aphatie
au balcon
mais le mec il sort ses fiches de l'ena
pour parler une poissonnière se dit
attends on prend des cours chez morano
un peu
ça c'est pour toi moi là je savais
alors le discours de vérité en banlieue
c'est qu'il faut dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'avenir madame ben franchement déjà
avec bac +5 les gens ils rament vous
imaginez un brevet des collèges obtenu
la courneuve
la preuve il est là
car il fallait des plus virils quatuor
web était gosse tu les tiens un peu ça
la fin du pardon et si c'est le texas
monsieur hollande non madame c'est pas
le texas c'est pas le texas ils ont du
pétrole
ils ont la peine enfin oui
enfin bon attention je peux faut être
sérieux la gauche et fait pas que des
conneries on dit qu'elle gère mal les
comptes publics c'est complètement faux
c'est quand même elle qui a réussi à
sous-traiter l'expulsion des roms aux
habitants quoi
c'est plus la ratonnade c'est la romana
international alors j'ai j'ai appris
qu'ils avaient retiré les femmes dans le
catalogue ikea d'arabie saoudite ça
c'est une erreur d'impression
porte atteinte à l'image de la femme
saoudienne ils n'ont pas affiché le prix
de la femme
quoi d'autre
géopolitique les otages au mali c'est
quand même malheureux arriver à se faire
kidnapper dans un désert
t'imagines la poisse moi j'aimerai pas
être assis à côté du mec dans l'avion
quand parti un peu ludique salon de
l'auto c'est important l'automobile ça
permet de conserver un levier de
croissance c'est un truc parce que sa
relance l'économie on connaît la
solution on dit que oui pour faire de
l'emploi et relancer c'est pas le coût
du travail le problème ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que les constructeurs français
soient capables de concurrencer mercedes
imagine le nouveau riche brésilien
devant son art à sa piscine son jet
privé qui voit et se dira il manque un
truc dans ma vie une kangoo
alors
[Applaudissements]
par l année les corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un peu de bleu